[music]
Sweet. So I will instantly uh reframe
the question from can Europe lead
physically AI to how can Europe lead
physically AI and how will we lead
physical AI because I have a lot of
questions about this. Uh we will do a
quick round of introductions. Uh I will
start with myself. Uh my name is
Andreas. I'm an investor in uh mostly
robotics. Uh I think we're currently one
of the most active investors in robotics
and early stage in Europe. I also do
policy work in Brussels. So if anybody
of you wants to know anybody thing about
politics,
come to me and traumatize me uh because
I uh work on a lot of those topics as
well. And uh I will head over to David.
>> Hi everyone, my name is David, founder
and CEO of Neur Robotics. Um what we do
is like we build uh basically cognitive
robots which can hear, see, feel, think
and react fully autonomously and for
that like it's a little bit more than
just robots. It's basically the brain
behind and the platform so everyone can
adjust it and contribute to it. That's
what we're doing.
>> Hey everyone, great to be here. I'm
Anastasis, co-founder, coco of Runway.
Uh we focus, we're a foundation model
company that's focused on video
generation and world models. So kind of
building uh kind of end to end kind of
systems for simulating, understanding,
kind of interacting with the real world.
Um a lot of our focus for a long time
has been video generation for content
creation, for making films, making ads,
making any kind of content. Uh and over
the past few years, we've been also
focusing on robotics. how can the same
models that are used kind of pre-trained
on large scale video data be used to
actually uh predict actions that a robot
can take in the world help uh generate
data for robotics to train.
>> Um this is Vicki um based in Seattle. uh
so scientific we focus on training data
sets and also provide a good quality of
the benchmarking data sets and
especially working with hyperscaler and
uh also physical AI world models. So
that's including you know what is in the
uh egocentric data um teleoper operation
data and also um realto theme data um
anything that you can think about and to
help robotics and to see things
understand things and reason things and
interact and working with humans and we
focus on the uh global skills so across
into uh 33 different countries and heavy
you know uh putting on the regulations
data sovereignty into our consideration
Hey all um this is Ankit. I lead the
international business for Uber AI
solutions. So somewhere in between a
ride and a burger. We ended up building
this massive network of infrastructure
around data operations really helping
companies get to the ground truth u be
it longtail edge case scenarios in
autonomous vehicle generally or physical
AI more broadly or in the genai world to
sort of understand how you can train
your models better with human in the
loop. um really scaling at 70 plus
markets that we are operating today. Um
and yeah, good to be here.
>> Cool. Um so I have basically three big
topics I want to cover. Number one is uh
the US versus Europe. Number two is
China versus Europe and number three is
training data specifically because right
now we're in this moment of like
reasoning models and vision models and
all this kind of stuff actually becoming
moving out of the uncanny valley and
like training data is a big part of
that. But before we do that, uh David,
uh you recently raised what I think is
the biggest round for any German startup
so far. Is it correct?
>> Yes, correct. What did you do in that
evening afterwards?
I think so. Um yeah, basically focusing
right now right away focusing already on
the next uh things. Uh we will have a
celebration actually this Friday. So uh
it came a little late, but that's how it
is. Um I think the first thing we did is
like we came back to the company and we
started to restructure the company
actually completely. So we had one week
of completely restructuring and now
going forward and building the
physically AI company for the world and
that's what we're doing.
>> I I can also imagine like that I so you
have been doing this for quite some time
now and this hasn't been like an easy
journey and like now also like this
massive round that must have been like
an insane moment for the whole team
right? Yes, it was for sure. It was
milestone, let's say like that. It's
like I think everyone in our company is
aware it's it's just a step between. I
mean, we are not done yet. We are far
away from there. Um but but we are now
let's say in the stage I think we're
like there weren't so many German
companies on the stage and I think it is
um for us it was a huge milestone simply
because uh it was uh kindly like it was
always said it is impossible to do
something like that out of Germany and
Europe and I think um to build something
which is impossible it just makes us
satisfied so we are having fun and at
the same time knowing also how much
responsibility it takes also for the
next companies coming after us. So, and
this is also what we are focusing right
now just succeeding so others after us
have it easier than us.
>> It's it's always impossible until
somebody simply does it.
>> Um
why is physical AI important for Europe
from your point of view?
Um yeah, I think I'm slightly biased but
I do believe um like physical eyes
actually the in my opinion the last big
chance actually for Europe actually
having built something which is
important enough or big enough also
going forward like um to to contribute
contribute actually also uh to uh let's
say be important to the world and why is
this so important simply because that's
the only thing why Europe exists and the
same time also why we having let's say
peace or we had peace and at the same
time also prosperity like the wealth we
have built was mainly built on our
technological advancement and because
the world was needing things we are
building now I think physical AI is
again a chance for us big enough
important enough because here we are
talking about let's say a technology
which is basically covering um the
biggest contribution of let's say the
global GDP or so I'm talking about
physical labor um like of 65% of the
global GDP is actually uh how to say it
done by physical labor uh work and and
this is I think a huge opportunity for
us uh to build something which is
important and um let's say how to say it
yeah that's that's it or
>> uh Anastasis um you originally from
Greece uh could you have started runway
in Greece
>> no
>> uh to put this into magnitudes what kind
of amounts of money do you need for your
current word models
Uh so we've raised in total about uh 800
million at this point. Um and that a lot
of that goes to research and scaling the
the video models that we train. Uh I
would say runway is a special story
because um I think it could only have
started in New York uh out of all all
the places like the New York you know we
started in uh in grad school uh in New
York and New York has this intersection
of creative industries technology um
like uh advertising media uh in a way
that doesn't that that's very difficult
to find anywhere else and so New York
has been a big part of like the runway
origin story. At the same time, a lot of
our research uh was done in Europe. Like
we have a research team in the UK and
now we're opening another office in in
Paris. Um our first I think our first
three researchers uh were kind of all
European. Um a lot of the progress in
image and video generation actually has
happened uh in Europe uh both kind of in
happened inside runway but also outside
runway uh in places like deep mind or um
kind of here there's a lot of a lot of
research happening in Paris as well um
so I think the story of like where
actually foundation models are trained
where research is happening is there is
a common misconception that it's all
happening in the Bay Area that's not
actually the case at all uh as we prove
uh being kind in New York and Europe.
Uh, and I think uh the the talent that's
here, the the level of rigor, academic
rigor, um the in physical AI, the kind
of deployment base that's in Europe
makes it uh you know gives a much larger
opportunity I think for Europe to uh to
succeed in physical AI maybe compared to
the pure world of uh uh of bits. That's
uh where I think a lot of the progress
has happened in the Bay Area. Um I used
to live five six years in the Bay Area
and I always joke that US startups are
just rappers for European, Chinese and
Indian talent. Um and it feels like with
a lot of the AI labs that like core
teams are usually like very frequently
core people there are European. Um from
your point of view as like a a Greek who
moved to the New York uh what would what
would you wish for Europe to change so
that the next Greek uh AI researcher
like can start the next runway in
Europe?
I think there's a few things. So, um I
guess a big important thing which I
think is improving is kind of the
funding environment. I think those es
especially the scale up rounds that you
know the AI companies are are getting
are very difficult to there's not that
level of uh kind of capital that's fine
in Europe at the moment. Um that's again
that's changing. We've had like really
big successful uh rounds happening uh
both on the model side and the um and
and the hardware side. But that that's a
big important piece like if you want to
train foundation models like you can't
do that you know scaling laws are real
you need to scale comput you need to
scale data um and that's that's
difficult uh that requires a lot of uh
uh a lot of investment in those areas.
Um and then I think uh it's I I I think
especially as we um I think there's at
the same time some opportunities for
Europe to stay ahead. I think the level
of collaboration that's happening with
different governments uh in Europe and
kind of partnerships with different
governments and there is some nice kind
of competition between like which
government will be more AI forward which
government will partner with AI
companies. that's creates a really nice
environment I think for for European
companies to leverage compared to the US
which is a more monolithic um monolithic
kind of uh environment. So so there is
like there is some opportunities now
with AI for for companies to to kind of
be more kind of strategic partners of uh
of governments in a way that didn't
really make sense with like the SAS
companies of the previous decade. Ankit
you are currently first of all can you
explain to people the difference between
Uber and Uber AI services I think a lot
of people are aware and then second of
all you're currently bringing uh
physical AI to Europe actually uh
especially in Munich with the robot
taxes and multiple other cities. Can you
talk about this for a second?
>> Um so it's funny we're sitting in Paris
today because if you walk down the
memory lane u back in 2008 this was the
place where Uber was born on a snowy
night. This was where the concept of the
founders realizing that they couldn't
find a taxi um was actually where Uber
was born. So, you know, when we started
to scale Uber, uh we quickly realized
that we can't just rely on sort of the
third party providers. If you were to
get your ETA right, if you were to make
sure that the driver is arriving where
the the rider is and so on and so forth.
So we spun up an internal team to really
start thinking about data and collecting
real world ground truth data to train
and the algorithms back then today known
as more models. Um and and over time
that sort of expanded into the labeling
into Uber Eat use cases and and last two
decades we've really been building that
for our in-house use case. 2024 we
externalized that because we started to
realize how important it is especially
in the physical AI world but also in the
Gen AI world data is super important not
just about access to real world ground
truth in 70 plus markets that we operate
but also more importantly how do you
kind of make use of that data so us
running the biggest gig workforce we
really truly bring that expert layer and
I think in the broad scheme of things
Uber's vision has evolved to not just
run the biggest marketplace of you know
moving people and goods from place point
A to point B but also evolve to running
the biggest gig marketplace for anyone
and any task you're a PhD with a lot of
specific degrees with spec specialized
skill set you may need that capability
to train certain specific models and
that's what Uber solution essentially is
um to answer your second question so if
I take a step back you know in 2020 we
sort of uh did a transaction for our own
autonomous one P model and move to a
pure partnership model because we
believe our end goal is to have every
robo taxi deployed on our marketplace.
And as a result today we partner with
almost all of the companies out there
that are building um robo taxis. Um so
for example we recently announced
autorains partnership in Germany with
momenta for example in Germany as well
and in Spain with vite. I think our goal
is to kind of make sure that we partner
with everyone. And this is where Europe
comes in interesting because, you know,
you've got some companies that are
building just the hardware, some
companies that are just building the
software, the AV 2.0. Um, and then if
you think about the uh the OEMs, they're
building the actual body. So, I think we
as Uber are trying to play the
orchestration layer so to speak, the
connective tissue uh from demand
generation all the way to fleet and
infrastructure. But before that actually
really providing the longtail edge case
scenarios. So next time you may take an
Uber in in the US you may not know but
there are sensors fitted outside that
are really helping collect data sets to
train a models too. Yeah.
>> So, so your if I understood this
correctly like because momentum is for
example like company from Beijing like
Uber is a company from the states. Lift
is now acquired a bunch of companies in
Europe and is like introducing uh I
think self-driving from BU if I remember
correctly. So where is like you just
said it but like just to repeat it like
where do you think in that stack is like
the Europe's role? Um I think Europe
plays in in the AV space physically when
we talk about physical AI plays a role
to a be the orchestration layer b I
think also the OEMs if you think about
all the OEMs outside of China and US and
most importantly all the leading OEMs
are actually based out of Europe so
there is a lot of sensor configuration
there's a lot of calibration that goes
on and there's a lot of settings that
needs to happen in the hardware setup
and that I think that's where Europe
will lead a lot so we've we've announced
partnership ship with Nvidia, Stalantis,
um Wave and us coming together. So
that's a perfect example because Wave is
building the end toend model, Stalantis
brings the um the OEM, Nvidia brings the
processing and the data uh piece and we
bring the data factory, the real world
data, we bring the data annotation layer
and we also bring the infrastructure of
operating and operational management. Uh
before we jump into OM which is a good
topic on this one actually uh Vicki you
also uh we as you called it like your
data factory company you're selling
globally like do you see difference in
how what customers demand and also do
you see industries or platforms
currently emerging that people don't
have on their radar yet
>> um we see that now this whole world uh
physical AI keeps evolving it's on a
daily basis uh I put into different
layers so first of all when we talk
about infrastructure readiness We mainly
dealing with older devices. We give you
example that now um we recently visited
ODMs major OEMs and hubs. We see that
it's not just producing robotics bodies
anymore. They are talking about
egocentric devices smart gloves where
that they can measure your fingers and
bones level. So that is gives you
density depth of what is the data set is
needed. So all the things not like a
GTP3 training uh where there's a large
data set existing in the world today
those data doesn't exist. So that's the
number one challenge. So all this
manufacturies and also labs and trying
to catch up what is the right devices
setup and that is needed for training
the uh uh physical ground model. Second
thing is now when they are dealing with
the models uh they nobody has to figure
out what is the data needed. So for
example if anybody catch Nvidia's
recently released they announced Cosmos
3 reasoning model they also announced
that they are trying to partners with
the people industry researchers in the
industry trying to see what is the
benchmark data sets it means that they
haven't figured out what is the kind of
data is needed rather than the quantity
of the data sets so that's completely
different way compared with the GTP
training third way if you talk about
academic world, you know, Fifi Le or,
you know, any of this world leading labs
and they are still trying to big bat on
whether they should um big bat on the
tele operation skill set and to get the
data set or the egocentric data or you
know real scene uh moder uh the
simulators. So nobody has to figure out
that so there's not a no answer that
people can follow the path. You have to
just be curious and then figure out the
answers together.
Um let's jump to OEM and hardware. So um
there used to be a saying in the last
few years that's thankfully going a
little bit away because it makes me
leave zoom calls with founders uh which
is hardware is a commodity we focus on
the software layer. Uh David do you
agree is hardware a commodity?
It's not. So and I think yeah it's good
if the other think that way but uh it's
actually not. Um the reason for it is
very simple. I think um even talking
about AI and data or like if you if
you're talking about physical AI then
the big difference is there is no data
for that like existing maybe there is
right now some in production but there
is not really a lot of data existing and
the other difference is actually that
the data comes actually out of what the
sensorization so and if you do not have
the right sensorization on you will
never have a brain understanding
anything of it because you never had the
data for it so and and that's actually
where where where we I think why we
actually built first of all also the
physical embodiment for the robots and
the second also like different
embodiment. The reason for that is
actually that we do need to define the
core one uh is the sensorization let's
say the fingertips uh like the
sensitivity on the fingertips. The other
is like uh vision the other part is
audio. So you have like a multimodal
version. Um and and then the other part
is actually the compute. Uh because even
if you tell me like there is already
everything set for that uh it's again
something is good if other think that
way but it's it isn't actually because
um if you're talking about physical AI
the difference is actually that you're
in a physical world which is dynamic. So
it's it's actually moving and it's
changing. So it means actually you need
to be reactive and and this you can't
learn that all with your brain actually.
So you do need to have like also uh
another nervous system and that's also
why I we're working a lot on and it's
what you're seeing right now in our
recent funding round is like we focused
on sensorization partners for that
strategic partner for the compute
infrastructure brain [snorts] nervous
system and then actually the cloud
compute and distribution and then going
further even for machine economy. So it
means also the the whole transactions
how how do you transfer knowhow like and
and how do you distribute it actually
let's say in in a way that everyone can
actually contribute at the same time
benefit from it. I think again sorry I I
took long for that but it's it's
actually not commodity yet so we do need
to define it and I think um and and it
will be one day but uh and even there it
will just get better and better but um
we are not there yet
>> also like um especially in the current
wave of startups if you're trying to
innovate some specific industry let's
say farming uh you can't just say let's
wait for a Chinese company to build an
automated tractor you have to build the
automated tractor and likely that like
half of your product development is in
hardware and not in software alone, you
know. So, um you you also like very
famous now for sourcing mostly if not
completely in Europe. Is this true?
>> Yes. Uh for the humanoid we are we're
right now trying to source almost 100%.
So it means there is some rare materials
whatever which we can't like get from
Europe yet. But um but the uh like all
their production and uh assembling
everything is done in Europe and uh
we're focusing like on that to build the
supply chain for that. So actually we're
transforming a existing supply chain of
automotive um into basically robotics.
>> What where do you see the trick to be
here competitive with China and like how
much full stack vert verticalization do
you need to do as neuro? So I think here
it's important that like first like we
are not against China and whatever. So I
think right now it's more to focus to
build the whole ecosystem around us to
actually be able to build an economic
pillar which is independent and at the
same time strong enough and actually to
actually arise from Germany and Europe.
I think it's important for the
beginning. I think in in the longer term
I I do believe that it will be let's say
global sourcing. I hope it will start
like because I'm still a believer in the
globalization even the world's right now
delizing
but I I do believe in globalization
because that's also the core for Europe
but for that we need to build first the
technologies which is important enough
which the world needs which is better
than something on the on other parts of
the world and then actually I think this
is and then we contribute again like to
the globalization part and um I I do
believe we will source everywhere so and
the cool thing about uh about physically
and robotics is actually but it's a huge
topic if I start but is actually um that
it's the only way in my opinion to to
actually let's say get production back
to Europe or in the same time also to us
I mean Donald Trump has a good idea like
bring all the production back to us but
the the difficulty he will have is that
the skill sets are not there yet so it
means actually it's the same actually
transferring like Apple transferring
basically um the production from China
to India it didn't work out the way they
they they wish and they expected or the
reason for that there's different skill
sets in um in uh in like in a population
or so and and this is I think the
difference in in physically and robotics
that you it doesn't matter where you are
you know on which part of the planet the
only way is in my opinion that's
actually the the future vessel of
knowhow and you can transfer it wherever
you want in the planet and I think it
will contribute to the globalization
again
>> I I want to chime in uh for that point
um I feel like that Europe has a really
good chance to um in terms of the
motivation the needs and get leading
into this physical AI world the thing is
if we look at uh Asia market US market
yes there's a fantastic companies and
especially in China robots can do
anything dancing you know movement and
nursing the people anything you can
imagine but the thing is now if you look
at how they make the money very few
company make the
Um there are probably between 20 or 23
companies really famous and including
some of the uh great companies on the
floor. Um if you ask them yes valuation
is um very much double digits but the
commercial model is very thin. The
problem they have is um the labor is
very cheap there. If you are making a
robot which going to help you to clean
your dish and mop your floor, there's
nobody in Asia is going to buy the
robots. they can just hire a nanny and
you know people assist in doing that
versus that US what we see is now
there's a huge labs doing all this
fantastic models they haven't really
figure out the answer yet but they
haven't also quite figure out how to
land the commercialized model they are
trying to get the manufacturers there's
a very limited the um you know robotics
OEMs and hardware ready for them so
that's a different focus so when I look
at Europe I feel like the manufacturers
is here the verticals and healthcare you
know all this needs is here um and you
know all Europe needs to do is to you
know catch up all this devices
ecosystems and infrastructure readiness
and then get the data which is not a
rocket science so that's just in my
opinion
>> uh it's a good point actually David what
is needed to make the vast supply chain
in Europe more accessible to startup
founders
>> it's the belief of the existing supply
chain or I mean we in like the reason
for us being so let's say going so deep
like in even developing our own sensors
gearboxes motors whatever has the the
the reason for that was that there was
um let's say the whole supply chain
existing supply chain was not believing
in that story of robotics and that this
will scale one day but I think this time
changed because you you do see that um
like especially like in in Germany like
the supply chain of of automotive is
really like I think they have they have
now a lot of energy actually or a lot of
hope in a lot of little things where
where they can actually um how to say
find a new market for them I think they
have to there's no other ways for them
to survive they have to find new markets
and things which they actually can
believe in bet on and actually go inside
the same time like not just for the
investors but also for themselves uh to
actually sustain in that space so I
think um it's it's getting accessible
because simply there is a need there is
a pressure there's uh like hope like a
lot of hopelessness or like in in in
that space of automotive supply chain
and I think and they're ready to believe
in in even little things and and and
drive them there so I think it's a good
time right now
>> I mean this is the interesting thing we
used to outsource to China because it's
cheaper labor then we realized uh then
they uh uh then we now outsource to them
because they are the only ones that have
like on that detail and that deaf and
breath the supply chain and now they're
starting to automate all of that and the
question is like we should just use the
automation to nearshore again and we
talked like to multiple startups that do
a lot of industries that we thought
about like pretty much gone to the to
the to China and to Asia like coming
back now because you can actually fully
verticalize and fully automate that
whole process. Um I have a question
because David said something before
about uh um data and like data not being
available in uh manufacturing and so on
and so on. Um and this might be a little
bit pointed question but our the reason
why word models are so popular right now
and like make such a huge progress right
now is because there's like a vast
amount of massive general data that you
can use to train the word models and
very little specific data to just like
do small thing for a specific purpose.
>> I think that's a good summary. So I
think the biggest the biggest problem in
uh robotics at least on the software
intelligence layer is generalization.
You want a robot that's able to not just
perform the tasks that it's been
pre-programmed to do, but actually be
able to follow arbitrary kind of
instructions that are, you know, in
natural language and be able to adapt to
situations that it hasn't seen before.
It hasn't been explicitly trained on. Uh
otherwise you're not going to build
actually systems that can operate in
kind of in the real world and can kind
of uh you know you you won't be able to
build humanoids that are in the home and
can deal with all the complexity of the
different layouts different environments
different household tasks uh kind of a
robot that will follow you around kind
of help you know go to the supermarket
come back to the house like perform
basically deal with the complexity of
daily life um and in order to get there
I don't I think if we can only get
there. If we train uh a model just on a
single embodiment, a single uh form
factor, I don't think we're going to get
there. We need to build a model that can
transfer from um especially essentially
human data. There is uh a vast amount of
kind of real world video of humans
performing different tasks in the world.
And if we can leverage that knowledge
and bootstrap to bootstrap models that
then need only very little amounts of
data from um actual robotic embodiment
then uh I think that's a much faster
path to getting there compared to
actually collecting that same scale of
data um just just com just uh with kind
of uh on just robotic embodiment. Um and
so that's the bed of world models is uh
you can bootstrap and kind of start kind
of cold start those uh those models by
just pretraining on massive amounts of
kind of human data of human of humans
performing different tasks in the world
and learning from that both kind of the
diversity of kind of tasks that humans
care about. Learn about physics, learn
about kind of the how the world works
and then use that as a starting point
for any work that you do in robotics.
Use that to generate data. use those
models directly to uh to adapt them as
action models that predict the actions
that the robots will take. Uh so we we
think that's a much faster uh and really
the the the the only path I would say to
getting to getting there.
>> Anit I work in Brussels, you work at
Uber. I give you one minute to become my
anger uh speaker uh about regulation in
Europe. Please go.
>> Interesting. You know, I have a
different perspective on regulation when
it comes to physical AI actually. Um, if
you talk about general tech, yes, more
regulation slows things down and it's
it's sort of the death spiral. But if
you think about physical AI, the biggest
challenge for scaling is safety and
scaling it at a point where it becomes
more efficient. And I think Europe
leading the way from a regulation point
of view might feel like it's taking a
step back. But if I think about two-year
horizon or three-year horizon, I
actually think because the regulations
are being set now, scalability in the
future is going to become much more
important. And I actually so my my view
is that what's happening in the
regulation world from a regulatory world
from a physical AI perspective it's a
good thing eventually that I think is
going to accelerate the the deployment
for example not just in the AV world but
in general physical AI world because I
think to your point about data right I
think world models so AV 1.0 to 2.0 So
as a perfect example, a lot of people
are now using general data to train
parts of the model and then they need
some longtail edge case scenarios to
train very specific data types for their
specific cities deployment and so on. I
think regulation there comes in very
handy because that will allow you to
actually accelerate let's say
deployment. You can launch Munich
tomorrow, you can launch Frankfurt next
week. You don't need to collect tons of
data and I think regulatory framework
allows you to do that.
Sorry, I'm not going to be angry, but I
think that's my
>> that was not what I was before, but it's
um Yeah, fair enough. You have to
represent Uber here, I guess. Um
Vicki, what is an uh uh because like we
spoke about self-driving, we spoke about
word models with luxury. What is like an
absolutely unique data set that you're
recently selling more and more of that
you haven't thought about like most
likely most people here don't have on
their horizon? Um if I just looking at
H1 of this year, we see that there's
several waves change. Um January to
March, we see there's a huge spikes that
all of a sudden um companies to jump
into egocentric data. What does it mean
is you just have a hatmounted devices
and put on the top of your heads and
start to collect the data. But very soon
we see that in this companies after
March they all died because of two
reason number one those data lacks of
depths and there's and angle 3D angle
it's just not there number two is the
data regulation there's right now
there's more and more countries put
strict uh restrictions in how to ship
the data globally so that's another
thing and then after March we see the
waves and start to shift to more like a
3D Datas uh versus even today's 4D data
plus there there is a spatial movement
data with sensing involvement. So what
does it mean is there's a higher
requirement uh to get the uh correct
devices so that it's just resolve the
first step of the the problem but then
second problems is where you going to
collect the data where you going to
create the data um I'll give you a very
detailed number when we look at the GPT
um u genai right now that's the um most
of the challenges is stay with the post
trainings in RJI S and H uh SFTTS and
all the things but the data annotation
is not a huge huge challenge here in
physical AI most of the companies still
talk about training data sets they are
not getting into the annotation yet so
that means nobody has to figure out how
to label the 3D 21 points and hand
tracking datas this is just one of the
examples so stay with that track we see
that now the second wave people start to
change the devices but they are still
like a changing from you egocentric data
sets to smart gloves. Look at the whole
world how many companies has a smart
gloves to figure out and that's just uh
one of the challenge I learn soon that
you see that there's a combinations from
you know VR data sets and the smart
glass data sets and so that's not it
just uh I feel like we're still on the
early journey in getting figure out what
is the data is the most effective data
and then we get the uh annotations and
how are you going to produce the most
effective data sets rather than two
hours out of the eight hours and how are
you going to increase to six out of
eight hours. So now those are the very
tactical problems we see is every day
>> and it's still the very early days. Um I
want to make two things. Number one, I
want to make a prediction. I think uh
next year it will be completely normal
that we will talk about robotic startups
doing fully verticalized production in
Europe at competitive prices to China.
Uh this is a bold claim.
I stay by it. No, I literally stay by
like I see a lot of stealth companies
right now. I I literally stay by it and
I also think that Neuro is basically
like like leading like uh especially in
the supply chain to make this happen.
And number two, the second thing I want
to do is I want to thank you all for the
discussion and um thank you very much.
>> Thank you all. Thank you.